aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas des aspirants
chefs qui sont au fourneaux ce projet-là
en fait c'est avec des jeunes médecins
qui sont en troisième année de médecine
et on vient en fin de compte leur donner
goût de cuisiner chaque jeudi ces 12
étudiants se rejoignent de l'école où
tellière de la capitale pour leur cours
de médecine culinaire une première
mondiale dans les universités
francophones
médecine culinaire moi j'adore ce terme
c'est vraiment pouvoir en fait offrir
aux étudiants une approche totalement
différente et en fait un des talents
culinaires celui qui a eu l'idée de
secours c'est Michel Lucas il porte
plusieurs chapeaux puisqu'il est médecin
épidémiologistes professeur à
l'Université Laval nutritionniste de
formation il a aussi récemment complété
sa formation de chef
on utilise beaucoup ce qu'on fait en
chirurgie en anglais on dit Simone voir
douanes le faire et après ça être
capable de le transmettre dans le cadre
de la médecine culinaire c'est qu'on
remplace le fer par l'expérimental c'est
important de cuisiner et d'expérimenter
des saveurs d'expérimenter des textures
d'expérimenter des techniques pour être
capable de le retransmettre par la suite
ça doit être moins fort
Sylvie dedain de Wally et chercheur
professeur en gynécologie et passionné
par la nutrition
quand on parle de quelque chose qu'on
aime puis qu'on connaît bien on en parle
bien alors que je pense qu'actuellement
quand on parle la plupart du temps à nos
patients sans avoir des notions autre
que des notions de lipides de gras et de
sucre je pense pas qu'on est capable de
transmettre des choses que les patients
vont retenir ça prend des compétences en
amont pour être capable de les intégrer
puis vous allez maintenir et aussi
d'innover dans le domaine de grandes
universités américaines telles que
Harvard et Stanford ont intégré la
médecine culinaire au cursus scolaire à
l'Université Laval le cours optionnel
est à laisser pour un an on a fait des
questionnaires pour voir quelles étaient
les besoins des étudiants et sa confirmé
vraiment ce qu'on a déjà dans la
littérature les étudiants se sentent
vraiment mal outillés pour conseiller
aider leur patients en termes de
nutrition les cours sont divisées en
trois volets un théorique avec une série
de conférences d'une quarantaine
d'acteurs clés en alimentation sur la
scène internationale on parle de santé
des hommes on parle de santé des femmes
on parle de tous les aspects sociaux
économiques de la de la nutrition toutes
les problèmes en fait de
d'accessibilité à la aux aliments etc
alors ce qu'on peut faire ce soir vous
allez prendre chacun 2 litres de
bouillon de volaille il va falloir
l'aromatiser le chef Eric vilain assure
le segment pratique du il enseigne les
bases de la cuisine méditerranéenne
végétalienne indienne sans allergène
éveille au bon développement des
habiletés culinaires de ces futurs
médecins la plupart vous savez pas trop
tenir un couteau on est rendu à notre
troisième course sur les 8 qui vont
avoir lieu et maintenant si je
débrouille très bien
[Musique]
oui vraiment
faut bien les laver parce qu'il y a de
la terre dessus au début ils étaient
peut-être un petit peu intimidé par le
chef mais après ils ont tout de suite
embarqué ils avaient du plaisir à
cuisiner avec moi puis apprendre des
choses je pense qu'il voulait apprendre
puis il voulait aussi savoir en fait
est-ce que par l'alimentation on peut
aussi se guérir
le troisième volet consiste à
s'impliquer socialement ils doivent
réaliser un plan d'action cette année
c'est cuisiner au suivant donc ils
doivent travailler en équipe pour
réaliser un travail qui porte sur la
médecine la nutrition mais avec des
actions de santé publique ils ont les
yeux qui brillent ils sont hyper
intéressés et à mon avis ils vont servir
de modèle
pour leur futur patient le fait de
savoir faire un bouillon de poulet
qu'est-ce que ça va changer dans votre
pratique avec des patients c'est
difficile de donner des conseils qu'on a
pas eu la perspective personnelle je
pense c'est sûr que ce collant nous
apporte en particulier c'est de pouvoir
nous-mêmes jouer un petit peu avec ce
qui est alimentation pour pouvoir
ensuite en parler avec plus de sérieux
avec nos patients c'est important que
nos professionnels de la santé soient
des autorités en la matière pour être
capable de marquer des points et
orienter des patients vers la bonne
référence dans les programmes de
médecine actuelle on effleure à peine le
sujet de la nutrition la plupart des
facultés de médecine au Canada c'est on
est même en bas de 5 heures par
formation leur donne quelques cours
mais vraiment rien de très très poussé
et surtout pas du tout une approche très
globale de la nutrition qui intègre tous
les aspects pas juste les aspects de
baisser un cholestérol ou
augmenter la consommation de fibres la
faible qualité alimentaire c'est le
facteur numéro
dans le monde donc avec l'augmentation
des maladies chroniques on peut pas
penser que notre société va être capable
de régler ses problèmes là sans une
prise en charge globale du patient dont
l'inclusion de l'alimentation les
médecins ont quand même la confiance des
patients il doivent connaître
l'alimentation et donc si on veut
préserver améliorer la santé de notre
population il faut c'est un passage
obligé alors pourquoi un tel cours
n'existe-t-il pas dans les autres
universités canadiennes chaque
enseignant et chaque médecin pensent que
sa matière est la plus importante depuis
quelques années on a diminué le nombre
d'heures de cours chacun en fait tire un
petit peu sur sa couvre mais couverte et
il la nutrition mais elle a pas beaucoup
sa place parce que malheureusement le
programme de médecine est de plus en
plus chargé pourtant le cours de
médecine culinaire fait fureur chez les
étudiants ça change de notre routine
physiquement on sort de nos milieux ça
change dans les objectifs aussi là on
est vraiment dans l'apprentissage
pratique plus que dans la performance
des notes ou la performance du contenu
de des apprentissages qu'on fait oh ben
là qu'on regarde en général nos coups on
dit oh on a encore 10 semaines de course
et bien non alors que maintenant il nous
dit on a pu cuisiner on a plus que 6
semaines alors ça pour nous c'est
merveilleux et puis à la fin de la
soirée une fois qu'on a cuisiné des fois
deux des fois trois recettes à ce
moment-là on s'installe tous autour
d'une table on mange et puis on discute
en fin de compte de ce qu'on a fait les
techniques qu'on a vu durant la soirée
trois professeurs passionnés 12 futurs
médecins une grande tablée une recette
parfaite pour partager un savoir et
faire évoluer la médecine de demain le
problème dans la société en fait c'est
la même chose que einstein disait je dis
on fait toujours la même chose pour
certains à des résultats différents
c'est ce que lui appelait la folie mais
je pense qu'on est dans une société où
on a un peu de folie puis il faut sortir
de cette folie là par des approches qui
sont totalement différentes pour avoir
des nouvelles évidences pour avoir des
nouveaux médecins
[Musique]